focus focus focus focus focus focus
focus focus focus well you just got to
put one foot in front of the other and
you know sometimes I think you for
myself it's easy to become distracted a
little bit and start trying to look at
the final with the final pictures gonna
look like and you know when you do that
you can you can easily become frustrated
with where you are at the moment so you
know my advice is just to focus on each
day and now you have a plan in place of
how you want to improve and how you want
to get better and you stick to that plan
and Trust the fact that you know every
day that you you know stick to the plan
I'll get you to you and result we're
very simple people at Apple we focus on
making the world's best product and
enriching people's lives I think some
companies maybe even the one that you
mentioned maybe they decided that they
could do everything we have to make sure
it Apple that we stay true to focus
laser focus we can only do great things
a few times only on a few products you
want to be totally focused you can't
take your eye off the ball when I had
troubles in the early 90s a major
article came out and it said very
strongly everything he touches turns to
gold and I believed it so I'd go out
with models at night instead of working
but that wasn't good and I remember I
had a big lease coming up and there was
a big show and I went to the show I said
don't worry fellas you can handle the
least you'll get it done when I came
back they didn't get it done and I would
have had it done a hundred percent and
then the market crashed in the 90s so I
had trouble but it was sort of an
amazing I wouldn't want to do it again
it was an amazing test of yourself
can you handle pressure how are you
under pressure are you smart you know
when when everybody's coming at you but
the common wisdom the old intelligence
idea is to diversify and what I believe
in this is something else is increase
your financial IQ you financial like
intelligence and instead focus and what
focus stands for is
focuses follow one course till you're
successful and so that's what I did in
1973 I signed up for my first real
estate investment course and I just did
it and did it and did it you know I
bought this one little $18,000 place and
I did it again
and I did it again and I did it again
until the point where I understood it
and then I went into becoming an
entrepreneur and I did it and I did it
and did it I'm still learning and I'm
still learning about real estate and the
reason in 1966 I got into oil when I
went to work for the Standard Oil
Company so today I'm still focusing I
invest in oil and oil and oil and I
don't diversify you know doesn't mean
they don't lose sometimes I lose
sometimes I make mistakes and all this
but I just don't buy good as with all
the bad if you're going to be successful
as it invested you know
diversification is good for the average
investor that's what you want to be have
a good life but what I'd rather do is be
able to know the good ones from the bad
ones the good investments for the bad
investments the good advisers from the
bad advisers and what's good for me and
what's not good for you because what I
do is not necessarily what's going to
work for you
and vice-versa here so that's why I
really think instead of diversification
or diversifying the new rules of money
say follow one course until you're
successful and then keep doing it
because once you find that way of being
successful you can do it again and again
and again what the problem will be some
of our younger generation today we just
want to jump and see themselves up there
overnight it doesn't really happen what
you need to do is to be very very
focused as a person and be dedicated to
whatever they you are doing it is not
really good for you to not wanna try
something then after a month you just
say no it doesn't work you jump into
something else I think you need to be
very very focused in what you are doing
once you believe in what you are doing
it should not take your either business
or job as something that you must do
okay you must take it as part of your
hobby if it's hard to be a hobby then
you do it better you have to keep
yourself focused on whatever your
ultimate goal is there stumble there
stumbling blocks all the way people get
laid off you have a bad game you get
traded from a team that you don't want
to be with but if your goal and your
focus remains the same that hey this is
going to happen and I know I have the
skills and I have the knowledge and have
the instincts to dig myself out of this
hole you will dig yourself out of the
hole you have to control the situation
don't let the situation control you
focus you know we talked about today was
just in my office I run my company much
like a team in sales and marketing like
offense and manufacturing distributions
like defense and Finance and ID or like
the special teams but what you find out
is that all those pieces the companies
that win are the ones that communicate
the best and it's not one teams on the
field at a time we're all in the field
at the same time and so I think the
ability number one to communicate and
number two to focus you know too often
you know I get pulled all the time of
you know what you guys should make is
you should make one of these or make one
of those and why don't you do anything
for pets and how could you go there you
know great brands or like great stories
and every great story has a beginning of
middle and end and our jobs to make sure
that every chapter of our stories make
sense the one in front of it makes sense
the one after it
class quits the famous Russian general
said focus on the few not the many and
the one biggest common the most common
air that I see in successful reasonably
successful business men and women are
that they try to do too many things and
focus on the few not the many I
Aundre person on number one you're in
the right place at the right time but he
has to be the right you in the right
place at the right time number two very
the why I say that is because the
definition of an entrepreneur or a
person in business or you're going to
person in a job is a person who solves
problems for people at a profit or for
pay so what are you you are a problem
solver the biggest mistake almost
everyone makes in the world of Business
and Finance and money is they go out and
they look for opportunities bad move go
ahead
what's an opportunity how do you know
it's almost impossible to mine like so
don't look for opportunities look for
problems look for problems solve a
specific problem for a specific person
duplicate that the end result is rich if
you want to be rich don't focus on money
don't focus on rich focus on solving a
problem a specific problem for a lot of
people focus on on signal over noise a
lot of companies get confused they they
spend money on things that don't
actually make the product better so for
example at Tesla we've we've never spent
any money on advertising we put all the
money into R&D and manufacturing and
design to try to make the car as good as
possible and I think that's but that's
the way to go
so before for any given company just
keep thinking about are these efforts
that people are expending are they
resulting in a better product or service
if they're not stopped those efforts
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed I love to know which of the
ten points we mentioned meant the most
to you as well as how do you stay
focused in your business and on the
tasks you need to get done leave it in
the comments below I'm going to join in
the discussion thank you again for
watching continue to believe
I'll see you soon